and by the way this next story until
maybe we'll take a caller uh john if we
have any callers let me know if we do
have called okay good so we got a uh a
story comes out um which is pretty
interesting on who's going to be
challenging um so mike uh mick uh
mulvaney says ron desantis tim scott and
dwayne johnson could seriously challenge
trump dwayne johnson trump in 2024 this
is an insider story former acting
white house chief of staff mick mulvaney
thinks just three people could seriously
challenge trump in 2024 for uh florida
governor desantis could give him a run
for his money south carolina tim scott
uh senator tim scott can give him a run
for his money as well as dwayne johnson
could give him a run for his money it's
a short list by the way there's one per
other person who could beat him which is
myself donald trump is yeah myself
himself that's what he's talking about
donald trump is sometimes his own worst
enemy when it comes down to campaigning
so but i mean my main part with this
story isn't trump it's
dwayne hollywood running
um can you see
you know rock running for office and
being a president can you see something
like that happening sometime i i
couldn't see trump doing it so i think
after treatment
i think anybody oprah could be president
you know musk can be president
for me it's just like who would you like
to see be president if you're like would
you see musk be president of which i'm
not talking about like i'm not asking
questions like hillary clinton or i'm
not talking a political who would you
like there's a meme maybe you could pull
it up vote for nobody this is this is my
political philosophy tuition 100
um and and and this is this is what i
believe is the way
to the best future
that's it vote for nobody nobody will
keep election promises nobody will
listen to your concerns nobody will help
the poor and unemployed nobody cares
nobody tells the truth that is the
nobody part that is who i'm voting for
sounds like uh give government less
power you know i like that i kind of
like you you know who's going to line up
and vote for that party
nobody i am just yeah
you know where you vote for that party
in your in your house if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]